Welcome back everyone this will be my new marvel
fantastic four video chris evans was talking
about coming back as a version of johnny's storm
sam raimi has also been talking on the doctor
strange 2 commentary about their john krasinski
reed richards of the fantastic four and marvel
just announced a really big comic-con panel that
they're having like they used to have like they're
doing the same thing that they used to do they
kind of set the last couple years out so we'll
get a bunch more footage and confirmations about
what's going on during marvel phase four during
the panel look at these two troublemakers
hey johnny how are you wicked car is that
new yeah it's a sonata let me pack it oh you're
not fitting your car in there if you're brand new
to the channel be sure to subscribe to get all the
videos of course i'll do videos for all this stuff
as it comes and real quick shout out to my friends
at nordvpn who has to sponsor this video normally
on my marvel episode videos i do giveaways for
disney plus memberships but some of you might live
in countries where disney plus isn't available
yet and you have to wait forever to get new
marvel phase 4 movies on streaming but with a vpn
you can actually change the location you access
content online from even if you live outside
the united states you can use a service like
nordvpn to sign up for the us or the uk version of
disney plus you can also use a vpn to stop anyone
from stooping on your browsing history which is a
really useful way to keep everybody from finding
out how many times you re-watched wanda going
after the 838 universe illuminati what mouth
r.i.p to the 838 universe versions of all these
characters will have to wait for other versions
to come from other universes in future movies
i'll add a link in the description below or you
can go directly to nordvpn.com emergencyawesome
so be sure to check it out they have a 30 day
refund policy just in case you decide that it's
not for you but the big news you probably heard
is that chris evans was talking about coming
back as different versions of his characters
talking about coming back as captain america
from the mcu like the captain america that we
remember but also coming back is his version of
johnny storm from the fox marvel fantastic four
movies or the classic fantastic four movies
however you want to think about them i know
there's some questions about which universes they
come from but i will explain that during the video
because fox had their own plans to do a big civil
war type of event with x-men versus fantastic four
kind of confirming that the classic chris evans
fantastic four movies were happening in that
classic x-men movie universe but this is the clip
of him talking about coming back as johnny storm a
lot of rumors that like you could come back in the
multiverse as another marvel character you played
johnny storm would they ever come to you wouldn't
that have intrigued you like um but i really love
that character but i think aren't they doing
something now with yeah look i i would love it
i would love it that would actually be an
easier sell to me than coming back as cap
you know what i mean cap is right so precious
to me and you know i i almost don't want to
disrupt what what a beautiful experience that was
but johnny storm i feel like he didn't really get
his day that was before marvel really found its
footing so uh you know i loved that role and you
know so obviously he's just trading on the idea
that doctor strange two multiverse of madness kind
of blew everything wide open they have the a38
universe illuminati with all the different amalgam
versions of characters with easter eggs for all
kinds of different versions all wrapped into one
really good example that is that patrick stewart's
professor x isn't meant to be the classic version
of professor x from those x-men movies his version
is meant to be a reference to many different
versions of professor x most notably to x-men
the animated series like they literally play the
x-men animated series theme song when he comes in
that yellow floaty chair which was featured during
that series fun side note 2 marvel is actually
doing a brand new season of x-men the animated
series they're calling it x-men 97 because it's
meant to be a continuation of the previous series
and supposedly it's going to be connected to
what's happening during marvel phase 4. that's a
bit of a curveball that they're throwing us but it
could be really cool like in the way that what if
does a lot of things that we're seeing during
marvel phase 4 referencing a lot of similar things
even though all the versions of characters we
see during what if are meant to be different
characters that we saw in doctor strange too like
sinister strange wasn't literally meant to be the
version of supreme strange that we saw during
what if he's meant to be a completely different
version but they were kind of riffing on what
they did during what if with the character
and the whole reason why chris evans was talking
about coming back as johnny storm is because he
was saying it'd be way easier for him to do that
like just a way easier sell for him to sign on for
something like that than it would be for him to
come back as his version of mcu captain america
and it was in response to the long time fan
theory that marvel should do a series or a movie
based on captain america's story of him returning
the infinity stones like what is that story
of his last mission ever since avengers end game
he's been saying similar things like that like we
did such a good job with that character the way
we ended that that he doesn't want to completely
trample on that so whatever script he came back
for for new captain america stuff it would have
to be a perfect script it's kind of the same
situation with robert downey jr's iron man
character like he's not quite as quick to come
back as the original version of iron man because
there are all kinds of twists to explain how you
can bring him back but he'd be much more willing
to come back in some sort of alternate version
of the character that's completely different
like the version of tony stark who became doctor
strange in a future timeline there was a really
cool deleted scene during avengers infinity war
where they did a twist like that where he kind of
briefly became a version of doctor strange
wearing the cloak of levitation and doctor
strange became a version of iron man and when he
was wearing iron man's armor they called him the
iron mage i'd hoped that they would pay that off
during doctor strange too because that seemed like
the place to do something like that but i think
because they swerved on a lot of their iron man
plans they just wanted to have loose references to
him i've already done a bunch of videos about all
the iron man easter eggs so they reference him
a lot but you don't actually see him on screen
and when they decided to do it that way it
just made less sense to include literal iron
man easter eggs like having a version of doctor
strange wearing iron man's armor some of the other
really cool deleted story lines and subplots that
we learned about in the pre-disney buyout days
like when fox still owned all these characters is
that originally like i said they had planned to
do their own version of a captain america civil
war type movie with x-men versus fantastic four
and that was going to be after first class had
come out the people who wrote x-men first class
said that they had been tasked in writing their
version of an x-men versus fantastic four movie
and it got pretty far along before they swerved
on it and decided to do x-men apocalypse and all
those future other x-men movies that were just
completely by themselves like they did days of
future past they brought back the classic x-men
cast and did a completely different thing with
those characters and then eventually you have the
disney buy out where things really do change it
sounds like the plot of their movie would have
played out in a relatively similar way where
someone from the fantastic four like johnny storm
human torch does something crazy and that sort of
sets off this big conflict between them and the
x-men but because they confirmed that the classic
x-men movies take place during the same timeline
as the x-men first class movies they did that
during days of future past just kind of bringing
both of those timelines together because they'd
also plan to do this fantastic four versus x-men
movie that also kind of confirms that the classic
fantastic four movies also took place on this same
earth where the classic x-men movies took place
and for those of you asking about where deadpool
was during that x-men versus fantastic four movie
i believe that this was happening before the first
deadpool movie had blown up at fox so behind the
scenes for them he wasn't that big of a character
yet but the other really cool detail is that the
fantastic four were actually supposed to show up
during deadpool 2 before they decided to swerve
on that and do all the stuff with the x-force plot
this is some actual concept art of the characters
and what they would have looked like during the
movie now post buy out when marvel owns all those
characters again they can do whatever they want
and chris evans can say yes to whatever he wants
to but all this chris evans coming back is a
version of johnny storm obviously that wouldn't
happen in the brand new marvel fantastic four
movie they're doing the new solo movie there's
been a lot of talk about them just continuing with
john krasinski's reed richards like even though
it was meant to be the 838 universe version of the
character and they killed him off during the movie
a lot of people think that that might have just
been a test run that kevin feige and sam raimi
were doing just to see how the audience felt about
seeing fantastic four inside the mcu canonized
because even though this is taking place in an
alternate universe if you look at the fantastic
four logo on john krasinski's chest it's the
same logo that marvel's been using in all their
teaser trailers for the brand new fantastic
four movie and it just feels like if they had
never planned to bring john krasinski back like
if it was only meant to be a one-off version
then they would have just changed the look
of the fantastic four logo so that it looked
completely different from the logo they're going
to be using in the upcoming brand new movie that
kevin cast john because the fans had a dream of
who the perfect reed richards would be and because
it's an alternate universe i think kevin said
let's make that dream come true i think what's
really going on behind the scenes is that marvel's
just trying to have its cake and eat it too like
they're not trying to pin themselves into a corner
and saying it has to be john krasinski but i think
they're just trying to see how everybody feels
about it so that when they do the fantastic four
movie they can bring in a totally different
actor if they want to or if it doesn't work
out and just say oh like the john krasinski
thing that was just meant to be a one-off thing
we always planned it that way even though that's
probably not the case that is a really clever way
for marvel to try out actors like okay we're gonna
do a bunch of multiverse characters here of these
versions with actors that we think might be good
as these characters and we'll kill them off and
if fans really love them then we'll bring them
back as other versions of these characters from
different universes but if it wasn't clear i do
think when marvel does their fantastic four movie
their fantastic four will come from an alternate
universe and it'll sort of play in with the whole
idea of the incursions secret wars in the
multiverse in general steven your arrival
here confuses and destabilizes reality the larger
the footprint you leave behind the greater the
risk of an incursion from our experience the
greatest danger to the multiverse it turns out
is dr strange an incursion occurs when
the boundary between two universes erodes
and they collide i just did a brand new doctor
doom easter eggs and deleted scene video from
doctor strange to and i talk about how their
fantastic four is connected to what's happening
during secret wars and all the time runs out stuff
the incursions that they're doing everyone click
here for that and click here for my brand new
thor love and thunder trailer video in easter eggs
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!